أه هذه الضربات على البنية التحتية للسكك الحديدية
في منطقة نيبال ، قال
قائد الجيش الإقليمي الأوكراني
إنه من غير الواضح الآن متى ستستأنف
خدمة السكك الحديدية العادية
ما يحاول الروس القيام به
بشكل جيد ، لكن ما يحاولون فعله هو
أنهم يحاولون فعل ذلك.  قطع
إمداد السكك الحديدية وعلينا أن نتذكر أنه في
أوكرانيا أه أهمية القضبان
فهي أكثر أهمية في
أوكرانيا مما هي عليه في
الولايات المتحدة وعندما تنظر هذا هو المكان الذي
يوجد فيه دنيبرو في الجزء الأوسط بشكل أساسي
من الجزء الشرقي
من البلاد أه إذن هذا طريق كبير
وتقاطع للسكك الحديدية بالإضافة إلى أن النهر يمر
عبر هذه المنطقة أيضًا ، لذا إذا حصلت على
دينيبرو وحصلت على هذه المناطق
هنا ، فستحصل على خطوط السكك الحديدية التي تأتي
من خاركيف تلك  التي
تنزل من تلك التي تتجه شرقًا بمجرد
قطع كل هذا ، ما ينتهي بك الأمر
هو حالة
يمكن فيها عزل القوات الأوكرانية عن
خطوط الإمداد الخاصة بهم وعن
التعزيزات  لذلك هذا
ما يحاول الروس القيام به ، فهم
يحاولون عزل الأوكرانيين ومحاصرتهم بشكل أساسي
في هذه المنطقة هنا في
الجزء الشرقي من البلاد ، لذا إذا
فعلوا
ذلك ،
فأنت تعلم أنك تكره قول ذلك ولكن
انتهت اللعبة بشكل أساسي للقوات الأوكرانية
في هذه المنطقة بالذات إذا
سُمح للروس بالمضي قدمًا على هذا النحو